vous connaissez bien les parents les
parents de Lola
relativement bien oui vous habitez dans
l'immeuble mais gardien ouais c'est ça
ouais du coup c'est plutôt quand on va
récupérer un colis un courrier
voilà tout ça et
c'est choquant vous avez revu
aujourd'hui depuis le drame pardon vu
depuis le drame non non ils ont disparu
de l'immeuble je les ai vu juste le jour
où il y avait les policiers et
vous n'avez pas encore retrouver leur
fille
comment vous avez appris ce qui s'était
passé
le jour de la de la disparition j'étais
dans mon appartement la police a frappé
à toutes les portes pour la recherche
m'ont montré des photos et
là
je me demandais ce qui se passait donc
je leur ai répondu
que j'avais la photo je la reconnaissais
pas dessus parce que c'était c'était une
photo où elle riait et du coup le visage
n'était pas le même donc du coup non je
voyais pas montrer aussi une photo d'une
dame avec un bonnet mais c'était c'était
une photo prise de des caméras de
surveillance je reconnaissais pas non
plus et
ensuite je suis parti au travail en
rentrant je rentre tard le soir je
rentrais à 22h et là j'ai vu toute la
police tout le système mis en mis en
place j'ai compris qu'il y avait un
homicide j'ai compris vous la
connaissiez la petite Lola vous lui avez
je l'ai croisé oui
ça a été un véritable choc pour vous
forcément oui ça l'est encore ouais je
suis je suis très perturbé par ça
je mon sommeil est perturbé je dors deux
heures je me réveille et j'ai des images
horribles qui me viennent dans la tête
quand je ferme les yeux
je suis au bord des larmes souvent
je suis seul dans mon appart alors je
cogite c'est
le silence
c'est vrai que j'ai l'impression de
vivre sur un cimetière
des fleurs partout des bougies
c'est oppressant
je rentre chez moi c'est c'est cette
atmosphère je pars de chez moi c'est
pareil donc oui je suis très ému tous
les jours
il y a quelques jours vous aviez croisé
celle qui aujourd'hui la principale
suspecte de ce crime affreux dans quelle
circonstance vous l'aviez croisé
il m'a fallu quelques jours pour
pour réaliser que je l'avais croisé
comme justement avec ce manque de
sommeil
on se remet tout en mémoire on refait le
chemin en arrière on se demande si on a
pu croiser ou voir quelque chose
et
c'est vrai que cette femme je l'ai
croisée quand je partais au travail dans
la cour elle était assise sur les
marches et un petit jardin
et
je me doutais pas enfin jusqu'à temps
que je vois sa photo que je que je
recoupe les choses et que je me dise
c'est bien elle elle avait des propos
incohérents en fait et c'était ça qui
m'a disait quoi
elle était avec un gamin un petit gamin
je passe 5 ans 6 ans
il jouait avec un petit chien sur par
terre cela pelouse et elle me dit
n'appelait pas le service sociaux parce
que parce que mon gamin galoche son
chien et elle est folle qui pourquoi
elle me elle me dit cette chose là c'est
complètement incohérent
et je continue à avancer il y a le
m'interpelle encore elle écrase sa
cigarette par terre et elle me dit ne
vous inquiétez pas je vais je vais le
ramasser je dis mais je vous ai rien
demandé enfin et puis j'ai pas j'ai pas
insisté je mais après ma réaction ça a
été ça ça a été mais
que fait cette femme dans la résidence
exactement il y avait pas de logique et
en même temps comme elle avait un gamin
je me suis dit elle est de la résidence
mais il y avait quand même quelque chose
d'incohérent je me suis dit mais cette
femme est folle
et vous avez entendu par la police
pardon vous avez été entendu par la
police
ils m'ont laissé un papier sous la porte
m'invitant à aller les appeler c'est ce
que j'ai fait hier et il m'a fallu
quelques jours également pour encaisser
le truc et bien sûr et même il m'a déjà
fallu trois jours pour me rappeler que
j'avais rencontré cette cette femme et
du coup ça a été je pensais que c'était
plus le moment justement hier de les de
les de les appeler on n'était pas
inquiété plus que ça de cette jeune
femme pardon vous vous étiez pas plus un
que ça quand vous aviez vu cette jeune
femme vous la trouviez incohérente voilà
mais bon on rencontre beaucoup de gens
qui sont pas forcément tous traînettes
et donc non non ça me ça m'a pas
inquiété plus quoi je me suis juste
demandé ce qu'elle ce qu'elle faisait là
oui effectivement nul doute que votre
témoignage va intéresser forcément les
enquêteurs à deux niveaux d'abord au
niveau de la personnalité de la
meurtrière présumée et puis surtout il y
a toute la question de qu'est-ce qu'elle
faisait là est-ce que c'est au hasard
comment ça s'est passé est-ce qu'elle
faisait entre guillemets des repérages
et ce qu'elle avait déjà la volonté
peut-être de s'attaquer à un enfant donc
c'est au cœur
je me demande si on sait pas qui est ce
dont ça vous êtes d'accord vous êtes
vous allez être au coeur de l'enquête là
c'est sûr c'est sûr parce que ça touche
à toutes les composantes
lors des auditions il y a eu 6 auditions
de la meurtrière présumée et le juge qui
finalement a décidé de la placer en
détention à détecter un risque de
récidive majeur c'est rarissime
l'expression qui a été utilisée ça veut
dire qu'il a dit il faut écartez tout de
suite évidemment qu'elle aurait été en
prison mais tout de suite cette personne
de la société donc est-ce qu'il y avait
déjà une intention de passage à l'acte
ça ça va être au coeur de votre
témoignage forcément Bruno vous dites
donc le soir de la disparition saviez
qu'on cherchait Lola
il y avait énormément de force de
l'ordre
qu'est-ce que vous avez entendu parce
que est-ce que c'était voilà cette bête
aussi traumatisant pour vous peut-être
que ça voilà
l'interpellation le le la découverte ce
qu'on sait qu'il y a des
mine de rien aussi il y a des policiers
après quand ils ont vu ce qui s'était
passé qui sont en cellule psychologique
voilà ils sont traumatisés vous
vous êtes traumatisé de tout ce que vous
avez vu peut-être entendu sur cette
histoire
ce qui est un traumatisme je pense que
c'est la c'est la promiscuité
c'est d'être aussi d'être au coeur
justement de qui vous a raconté ce qui
s'était passé après vous l'avez lu dans
les journaux mais quelqu'un de
l'immeuble vous a dit voilà ce qui s'est
passé
le lendemain je suis sorti de chez moi
et j'ai vu qu'il y avait déjà des
premières fleurs posées
et qu'il y avait
[Musique]
il y avait des gens qui pleuraient donc
j'ai demandé à cette à cette femme qui
pleurait qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
il y a elle m'a raconté brièvement on
l'a retrouvé dans une malle
et là j'étais vraiment choquée parce que
oui je m'attendais
à une nouvelle puisque ce que j'avais vu
quand même toutes ces forces de l'ordre
et toute cette équipe technique si on
multiplier qui est qui était là donc il
y avait forcément quelque chose de grave
mais je ne m'attendais pas à ce que ce
soit à ce degré là
et oui très perturbé par ça
les autres habitants de l'immeuble alors
je ne côtoie pas beaucoup beaucoup de
gens
alors justement ce qui est ce qui est
très bizarre mais ce qui est normal
quelque part c'est que l'ambiance est
complètement plombée dans l'immeuble
alors que moi je suis arrivé il y a
quelques mois je suis arrivé au mois de
mars c'est récent et
donc oui j'ai parlé à quelques personnes
mais justement j'ai trouvé que c'était
une résidence calme j'étais assez
content parce que c'est sécurisé
[Musique]
j'étais fier d'être là et aujourd'hui
je sais que vous n'en pouvez plus vous
ne dormez plus
j'adore très mal je suis obligé de
prendre des de la mélatonine pour dormir
et d'autres choses pour
plus vivre dans cet immeuble vous avez
dit je ne peux plus vivre dans un
cimetière oui c'est les faits que j'ai
parce que dans un dans un cimetière
c'est un lieu où on se recueille un lieu
où il y a des bougies où il y a des
fleurs comme ça les gens y penser à tous
à tout ce qui s'est passé
en permanence en permanence je ne
heureusement que je travaille et que je
travaille dans un milieu qui bouge ou
qui est festif ça me permet de d'avoir
de bref instant de joie et de sourire
peut-être de désinvolture mais j'ai
l'impression que ça m'a retiré une part
de bonheur
je suis vous êtes anxieux chaque jour à
l'idée de quand vous rentrez chez vous
oui tous les jours vous avez pas envie
de rentrer non j'ai pas envie d'ailleurs
je déménage c'est ça d'ailleurs vous
déménagez parce que vous n'avez pas vous
sentez pas continuer à habiter c'est que
vous avez vous êtes très très stressé
quand vous rentrez quand vous
voyez tout ce qui s'est passé quand vous
voulez vous voulez vous l'essayer voilà
de de vous partir de tout ça parce que
ça ça vous a beaucoup beaucoup affecté
ça m'a ça m'a vraiment affecté après
c'est vrai que le fait de vivre seul
peut-être que la solitude m'a est
beaucoup plus pesante dans ce dans cet
immeuble
et les gens m'as sont devenus des
zombies certains on se regarde plus
les gens baissent les yeux ou justement
des visages l'autre est-ce que vous avez
revu la sœur de la principale suspecte
qui habite dans l'immeuble je ne la
connais pas la vie est jamais vue non je
sais même pas à quoi elle ressemble
d'accord donc voilà vous savez pas si
vous l'avez croisé ou pas si elle est
toujours dans l'immeuble vu que je sais
pas ouais vous savez pas du tout
les parents non plus de de Lola vous ne
les avez pas recroisés vous les croisiez
avant
et aujourd'hui c'est vrai que on a
l'impression que pour vous
il y aura vraiment un avant et un après
dans votre vie
et que vous vous êtes très très affecté
d'avoir été
témoin et acteur malgré vous de drame ce
que j'ai envie c'est bizarre de dire ça
mais j'ai envie de d'oublier mais on
peut pas oublier ce que j'ai envie
d'oublier peut-être c'est la douleur
c'est c'est tout ce côté sombre
et après on se on
culpabilise même de rire ou de d'avoir
un peu de joie c'est ça c'est vrai c'est
vrai c'est vrai que tous les toutes les
personnes qui me regardent on ne fait
que de penser à ça c'est vrai alors on
essaie de rigoler on rigole on essaie
voilà de vous divertir aussi tous les
sens mais c'est vrai qu'on a toujours
dans un coin de sa tête ce drame et
d'autant plus vous qui habitez dans
l'immeuble donc tous les jours quand
vous rentrez quand vous partez
toute cette
j'en viens à regarder par ma fenêtre
avant de partir de chez moi pour savoir
si je vais sortir par là ou s'il y a pas
trop de monde il y a beaucoup de gens
vous les croiser personne on allait des
badauds
c'est c'est pesant d'être la cible
l'heure sur le regard de tout le monde
en permanence
c'est c'est lourd j'ai la nation qui est
traumatisée donc a fortiori monsieur qui
habite qui habite là pour lui c'est vrai
que ça devient entre guillemets
invivable parce que c'est un lieu que
vous ne voudriez plus voir c'est
terrible est-ce que c'est ce que vous
ressentez je me mets à la place des
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent ce
soir est-ce que vous vous dites dans
votre tête je l'ai vu j'ai parlé
à la présumée
ou pas la présumée meurtrière de de Lola
est-ce que vous dire pensez ce que vous
dites j'ai joué parlé j'ai eu un échange
avec elle
c'est vrai que ça peut aussi traumatiser
de se dire ça oui ouais
et évidemment on se fait plein de plein
de films
au gardien c'est ça on culpabilise parce
qu'on n'a pas pu faire quelque chose en
amont et
même après on se demande est-ce que
est-ce que soi-même on aurait pas pu
être sa cible
est-ce que ce soir là où je les rends
rencontrés si j'avais peut-être le temps
si je travaillais pas j'allais juste
faire des courses et que je revenais
peut-être que qu'elle qu'elle m'aurait
interpellé sur un sujet j'aurais
peut-être parler avec elle elle m'aurait
peut-être aussi entraîné dans je sais
pas quoi enfin tout peut arriver avec ce
genre de personne et mon le drame c'est
survenu sur Lola cette petite fille de
12 ans ce drame qui je vous dis
bouleversé toute la France ils
continuent à nous bouleverser et je sais
que dans l'immeuble il y a énormément de
gens qui sont dans votre dans votre cas
qui
n'y arrive plus et qui n'arrive plus à
dormir à vivre une vie normale et on
peut les comprendre puisque même nous
tous ceux
voilà tous ceux qui pensent à ce drame
et on est nombreux on a du mal à oublier
leur imaginons imaginer imaginons quand
on était dans le dans l'immeuble ou le
drame s'est passé
et on comprend que c'est ce soit
difficile en tout cas pour vous Bruno je
sais que vous allez des bientôt
déménager mais c'est vrai que le drame
qui est survenu je pense qu'il sera
toujours dans votre tête dans votre tête
et dans nos têtes
en tout cas merci Bruno
merci beaucoup